as a debt collector or a hired heavy it
can always go wrong such as the day that
I had to go and have a chat with someone
I had somebody walked over and saw the
back of their head wrapped up into a car
with Mr T oh yeah yeah drove all the way
to where I live wrapped up in a bit of a
car and when I opened the boot the car
and took the tape off it was the wrong
encaser
you know it says quickly oops
where did we about to grow up I'm
actually from Ramsgate which is a little
town down South East and David you're um
I'm Peckham Marcus as you know as I know
don't pick him and I have a great
respect for um
Seaside domain you're a safe side person
you're what we call up a candy floss
cruncher and we love you we love you a
southern softie kiss me quick at wearing
Hard Knocks it's beautiful yes
yeah when did we meet was it 30 I was 28
yeah it was 32 years ago 32 years ago
yeah and we met and the ministry itself
the Ministry of Sound we both owned our
own security company yeah yeah both
owned our own security company and it
was very handy for me to
called upon him for some of the biggest
jobs I've ever had I've created a
funeral now and it was very anti-fream
whenever he needed numbers so there were
quite often things crossed over as well
didn't they people people might come
down from London and cause problems in
in my my manner if you like and I'd ring
you and find out it was it was doing
what fighting is something it's the same
as any other sport you can't get good at
it unless you do it a lot yeah and
seaside dormant in the summer there I've
got 52-seater coaches of men going down
to Margate to get all day long and have
fights I said I mean you shouldn't work
it out right it was like I mean how many
fights is that an average person who's
you know normal person how many fights
does he have in his life he might have
five or six fights in his whole life
right when I was working as a young
doorman on Margate seafront
um there was for starters there was no
big numbers of Dorman there was no
radios there was no licenses but I was
having probably three fights a night
right and when I started off I was only
working sort of three nights a week but
then I was working six nights a week as
a full-time dormant and having even more
situations to deal with and when you
think about it if you only had one fight
a week yeah and over a 10-year period
there's 500 fights yeah but when you're
having like 10 fights a week and I've
done it for like 40 years
so you had to also being very modest
Marcus I know you've heard more than
three fighting oh yes
I'd just rather than Saturday night on
Margate Seafood
500 coaches of 52-seater drunk londoners
you had you had a good 10 maybe 15
proper full-on scraps per day yeah and
in a night yeah exactly the weekends
were the worst I mean the weekends we
used to get all the coach buyers we
would get on average during the summer
70 big coaches come down from London
they're burning man in the 80s before it
all got a bit friendly when all the
pills come out and all that but in the
80s when all the football violence was
going on we wouldn't just get coach
positive geezers we get coach power is a
mill coach parties of West Ham coach
parties of this and that so when they
all suddenly bumped into each other they
come from different parts of London for
a day out to Margate when they suddenly
bumped into each other in Broncos on the
seafront or whatever it was like a
free-for-all so it was this coach party
fighting this coach party and then
there'd be like four or five dormants
trying to sort out those hundred people
you know it was awful it was it was hard
work
the first serious fight I ever got in I
was actually 13.
right and it sounds really silly you
think I'm a punch up at school no I used
to knock around when I was 13 I was five
foot eleven I was already sneaking in
the pubs right I was at 13. and um I
just hang around with Lads that were
about five years older than me and
anyway one day we were outside this bar
in Ramsgate and it kicked off between
these two little crowds and his fellow
pulled a knife out and stabbed my mate
in the stomach yeah and I and I didn't I
didn't even think about it I just ran
into the middle of the fight and I
grabbed the knife off the fellas I broke
the knife in half and threw it across
the road and then I bashed him and then
I dragged me mate to the hospital so
that was the first I would say serious
moment in my life at 13. I was a late
starter with the fighting man just to be
quite honest my biggest Accolade was I
went sparred with Lenny McLean in front
of everyone so he's standing there in
all this Glory again
oh God and I thought wow it is an
opportunity yeah to actually get in the
boxing ring with Lenny McLean you know
what I mean Legends and he can't really
do anything because it's
you've got someone to sit on your
shoulders
they'll never go I had the best kit
you've ever seen it was a wicked kit I
just weren't any good at it it just went
any good here so it gets in the ring it
wasn't actually really nervous I was
excited to actually be smiling anyway
it wasn't listening ding ding and this
is the truth as soon as it started he
just went
but
[Laughter]
I remember guys coming for jobs as a
dormant and they were like really good
in the gym on a bag you know fantastic
you watch the Visa worker punch bag you
think Christ he's going to be really
good dormant but then when you get a
coach party kicks off where's he gone
you know what I mean it it's it's a
different sort of person to do that job
and you do get it's amazing what you can
get used to though when you are working
like you said in that Seafood situation
it's amazing what you can get used to
you know it becomes the norm you know
it's oh we've got to fight another coach
party you know what I mean it's like
yeah for someone that isn't used to that
oh you until your mates fighting 52
drunk eaters is a nightmare but because
you get it every single day every week
you do it you become better at it yeah
it's not robbing the bank
oh you know yeah the more you do it
there usually eat
I don't think you can learn to have
bottle no I actually believe you're born
with that yeah a little bit more in your
first year that as I'm fully aware but
you can't learn too no you can't make
someone profession right now you might
learn all the moves on a bag yeah you
might feel braver with your mates
massager but when the Japan
you can't learn to go I'll have a bit of
that yeah so it's a reaction it's an
actual reaction it's a spontaneous
reaction when someone kicks off some
people run into a burning building some
people run away from it tell me it's
that type of thing
we had a coach party one night that
stormed the doors of the bar we was in
and there was only two of us working and
uh we ended up out in the street
fighting with him in an open area which
is never good and one particular guy I
think I'd hit him three times knocked
him on his three times but he just kept
getting up and you're in the middle of
like everyone's trying to get to you to
you know hit you to punch you to kick
you and I went to do a roundhouse kick
on this fella and he caught my foot so
I'm standing there on one foot and on my
leg in the air and he's holding on he's
as shocked as I was he's caught his foot
he's like right but I couldn't reach him
with like me with me fist because it's
not as long as my neck and uh so I just
ran my hands straight into his eyes as
hard as I could and his eye just came
straight out on his cheek
um and needless to say he went down very
hard and he didn't get up after that one
that night particularly when we were
fighting for our lives I mean literally
two of us fighting a coach party in the
street and I think it was only the fact
that
um about six of the locals saw what was
going on at the window and it came out
in High Street to help us and sort of
you know sort of that's the only thing
that broke it up I think otherwise we'd
have both ended up probably dead or
seriously injured Hospital
I've actually been shot yes yeah that
was the worst thing that actually
happened to me on the tour of a
nightclub I was shocked
he shot me in the leg and blew my ankle
out in the road
what actually happened was how do I
known for half a second it was
an enemy or anything
A car pulled up a yellow escort Mexico
black vinyl roof pulled up about 30 foot
away
I went Courtney Dave Courtney
and whoever he could have shot me from
there I doubt it because shooting
someone is not as easy as it looks no no
it's not as you know
and you know nine times out of ten
you'll actually miss a whole human body
you've got to be good I didn't know he
was gonna do that and I went yeah and
then walked all the way down to the ah
all the way to the window as I actually
was looking down like that to say yeah I
see him going up like that and that's a
gun he's pointing at me he's pointing at
that and I'm thinking oh
okay and he's actually aiming for my leg
but I didn't realize it so he's gone
bang but in my eyes he's gone yeah slow
motion yeah
and then he's gone down a bit you know
I'm not going to get in the stomach and
get it in here oh no he's gonna shoot me
I'm thinking to myself jump I don't know
what the thought I was going to do jump
out I don't know what I was gonna do I
did jump and then just come down and
shut me in an egg and what it actually
felt like
with something as big as you creeping up
behind me with a great big Sledge Emma
I'm going what on my ankle and because
both feet were off the floor at the time
it took my ankle and my foot right
upside down like that and I come down
and landed on my face boom Oh Dave
you've been known for carrying your
knuckle duster around do you still do
that no
[Laughter]
um
should I tell him the new law yeah right
the the law of knuckle dusters yes
um has changed in September
which means you cannot own a knuckle
duster in your house as an ornament even
at six months but I am a firm believer
as you know and I genuinely feel
the reason that knuckle dusters became
so popular that was my weapon of choice
all right the reason being is I firmly
believe that you have to be prepared to
do the bird the prison sentence that
your choice of weapon carries and if you
choose to carry a knife that means every
fight you have right you risk getting 13
20 years every five years
to risk not they're not dying on me so
that
all right I don't care who you are in
the world a knuckle dust you're a smack
in the mouth of a knuckle duster you
only need one punch going that way to
connect and you win the fight as you
know Marcus did you have a weapon of
choice a weapon of choice yeah
no never
um how I met the crazies I then had most
probably the biggest dormant company
in definitely London I would say Great
Britain at the time I had a couple of
thousand men working for me up and down
the country and they actually wanted to
know who this state Courtney fella was I
then got to visit reg to sort out
contracts of whatever it made he was
going to get his little bit and we we
struck up a friendship straight away and
I then visited him
once or twice a week for the next 20
years you know I've become very very
close with him I went to visit Ronnie
and brought more a good few times or
that's how Reggie asked me to actually
do the the funeral for Ronnie and I was
just I was usually I was there legs and
arms as you know yeah
for the next 20 years anything they want
you doing
and I was a young man in eager to please
and had had the manpower to do it and
I've done more or less anything he asked
me to do which in hindsight I wouldn't
have yeah but I was usually impressed
yeah and all of a sudden it's like
you're known associates
it allows the authorities that known
associates yeah to get away with an
awful lot of
not right Behavior the main one at the
moment I could think of is that the
craze funeral when when you got asked to
do the security on the first on the on
running Street and we'd only sort of
known each other probably a year or two
years or something like that and it was
quite early days you know but you got
the contract for that and it was a big
job you had to get hundreds of people
together to do that which you did
um but and you asked me as well which
and I and I bought another fellow up
with me um Andy kopez who absolutely
don't know he was like a real fan of the
craze had all their books and everything
and and I think you actually got
arranged to get him to go and do one of
the visits in prison as well which made
his day but again you know we because we
appeared in the papers and on the TV all
of a sudden we were saying they'll just
be sort of focus on us you know so it
wasn't it wasn't just Marcus the doorman
who you know they were looking at in
Margate in fact what's he doing up there
what's he doing up there with all these
gangsters and villains so and I know you
had exactly the same in probably 10
times worse to be honest with yourself
oh certainly it caused so much attention
for me and I said totally the wrong
attention well you're right you can
imagine what had done for me that was
the police's it's come out in in court
they're they're very first visual proof
of organized crime that's how they
looked at that funeral yeah criminals
are supposed to down little dark alleys
with a collar up no pictures no comment
and all that and I was standing there
with 150 of what I thought was the most
tasty I've known you know which was
hand-picked Mr Liverpool Mr Margate Mr
Newcastle Mr Glasgow Mr Mentor I had the
hand-picked firm uh which at the time a
lot of them didn't actually get on with
each other and that was what was going
to ask why we needed security for the
funeral because there was going to be an
awful lot of people there that weren't
actually yeah
luckily for me yeah for the monarch of
the underworld you know Ronnie Craig's
funeral everyone behaved himself but
after that they thought it was one
gangster one criminal organizing every
other criminal so they thought in Great
Britain all to come and work together
for the Celebration Death of another
criminals
ruined my life I'll come out in the
newspapers and I was
um celebrity gangster you know heir to
the throne like which really weren't my
thing I was running a security company
like you and fought with the amount of
pressure I'm going to get for doing
Ronnie's funeral this has got to be good
for me when I started getting famous you
get for being naughty then let's know
what you can be exactly that yeah but I
mean I wasn't even naughty I was just
doing what I did with security so all of
a sudden you know you know that sort of
noise
how about the very first time I met
Charlie Brunson
the very first time I met Charlie
Brunson I was in the special unit at
belmarsh I was in prison for
umbromand for my very first night for a
five million pound importation uh charge
of cocaine where I was arrested at
Heathrow Airport I remember my very
first name
and I was in the special unit at belmos
which is well and I was just lying there
looking out the window at two in the
morning going wow what the trouble of
mine now and for no other reason then I
took a little bit of his glory upon him
caught his name to Courtney's Niche you
know a little bit of thin and I'm lying
in bed and this is a very good
impersonation of Charlie I'm lying in
bed and I heard Courtney
Hellman
cool day I've only got one one chance
here there might be someone else in here
called Courtney that's the only chance I
have Courtney said I'm gonna buy an owl
in your chest and suck my life out of
you
and I'm not fried to voices on the phone
or anything like that like that there's
a time I've learned there's one time I
was trying to remember now yes there's a
time I'll find out and I could eat a
whole prison or going Bronson stuck in
Courtney Brunson stuck in cold choking
Through the Windows 500 people all going
oh what's gonna happen here I'm like oh
God oh my come on me it's me Toby oh
because I didn't I had no idea that in
solitary compartment I was never ever
going to bump into this man to smoke
like that yeah well I had no idea I
weren't going to bump into him in the
library the gym they can't aim the
church and I known he would have I would
have never bumped into him I would have
gone to the window with a different
height at least I would have done that I
didn't know
in front of everyone I can't even deny
that because 500 people earned it you
know what I mean but that's how I met
Charlie and since then
and through
joint Fringe that we have and all that
you know I mean I'm a little bit of a
Charlie
um
are promoting me I feel for him I'm not
a fan I actually feel for the yeah
you've got a bit of empathy for it yeah
and we became friends afterwards I've
had both of his weddings that he got
married in I had the reception at my
pubs he said he used to draw in pictures
and things and said yeah
beautiful eyes
having a large selection of dormant
working for you
what that was in my eyes was it was a
job center for a load of naughty men
right now if you needed your debts
collected a car repossessed someone
giving an ID into somebody thrown out of
a place that was so squatting in you
might not know anyone to do that but the
doorman no we always did we did and
because we had so many doors working for
us we had an army of naughty men so
whenever you know it was a job center
for him whenever he wanted would people
come and ask me to do so I mean I knew
someone to bash him up to get your car
repossessed to throw the squatters out
so I was involved in I wouldn't I would
call that crime though I mean no no we
don't call it a crime so we're in charge
we call it we're doing we've got our
Robin Hood out on yeah we're helping
yeah we're debt collecting yeah I mean
you owe it to him I'm trying to get it
back yeah someone has a debt then I
should pay it and if yeah in those days
you didn't have to have a license to do
debt collecting did you did you just you
said it'd be big
dark in someone's doing my job was
kicking someone's front door down and
going in and getting the money off and
with whatever way I I actually get the
money off of him I kept my rubber nood
out and Justified it with myself because
he owes him x amount of pounds I'm not
robbing him I'm just getting his money
back so one person he's making it right
would call you the Devil Himself yeah
and another person would would call you
an angel and after doing the croatians
funeral and everyone in England knew
what I looked like I could no longer
kick a door down no I could no longer
punch someone in the edge because that
guy it was Dave Courtney I know I must
see anyone in Sally I did I did the same
as you I did debt collecting I did some
repossessions I threw I got squatters
out of people's house I know you did it
on me
yeah but I didn't look at that that's
that's for me it's not a national
criminal activity that's so it might be
bending the law a little bit but it's um
to me it's just adjusting I mean yeah I
went to one of my friends at a place in
Brighton and it's quite as it was his
granddad's house he died it was everyone
it was in Probate and being sorted out
squats moved in they broke in they
didn't you know legally get in but they
put they registered to squat and they
put a big sign in the window you know
you cannot force up any removers from
this property they've got electric
turned on in their name everything and
he and he went to a solicitor and they
said I was going to take that over a
year to get him out well it took us
about 10 minutes
you know what I would say as a debt
collector things do go wrong in whatever
you do is your chosen job as a debt
collector or a
hired heavy because you do go wrong such
as the day that I like to go and have a
chat with someone I had somebody walked
over the top of the back of their head
wrapped up into a car with Mr T oh yeah
yeah drove all the way to where I live
wrapped up in a boot of a car for my
little speech to him before he goes to
court in the morning and when I opened a
boot the car and took the tape off it
was the wrong geyser you know it
says quickly oops
you know you know I have actually gone
around to do some debt collecting with
people throwing it from the garden
furniture through the back windows
no 37b
ah right sorry
regrets I've got a few regrets yeah I
have woke up with some very ugly women
regret
I haven't got an awful low regression
now
I wouldn't say I've got any regrets
either
not really
I should have retired a bit earlier have
you retired yes sir yes I have
one Bank
um who didn't give a toss for their
customers they were told if a Armed
robber comes in don't matter if there's
customers there drop down beyond the
counter they can't shoot for a
bulletproof screen what about the
customers customers got to take their
chances